la competencia oficial continúa hoy en
cannes como todos los días con dos
películas un filme finlandés y el
regreso aquí a la casa del actor y
director estadounidense sean penn que
viene con una película filmada junto a
dos de sus hijos pero aquí en cannes
estamos todavía con resaca de ayer por
la presentación de benedetta la película
del holandés paul a ver joven una
película que impactó no por la temática
que ella es polémica los amores
homosexuales de una monja en el siglo 17
en italia sino por la manera en que está
filmada y como mezcla el drama con
escenas de comedia que descolocaron al
público sino hoy también se presenta una
película latinoamericana en la sección
una cierta mirada la civil es en
realidad la película de una directora
rumana pero hecha en méxico con una
temática muy mexicana como es el
secuestro de una adolescente por el
narcotráfico un adolescente que es
buscada por su madre